[Musique]
la 40e réunion du comité des ouragans de
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
se déroule en ce moment même c'est à la
batelière ici en martinique des experts
météo de la région du mont pour évoquer
l'une des plus grosses menaces que nous
connaissons la saison cyclonique bonjour
jean noël de grâce bonjour maurice
bonjour à tous vous êtes responsable de
météo france où la vente à jean-noël de
grâce un tel colloque c'est pour bien
comprendre que nous ne savons pas tout
et qu'il faut elle a simplement continué
à chercher à analyser pour mieux
prévenir en termes durs à dents oui il
ya beaucoup d'objectifs mais c'est
surtout de montrer que on ne peut pas
travailler tout seul sur la prévention
des risques sur la mitigation des
risques sur la diminution des impacts on
est dans une région qui est fortement
impacté on l'a vu l'année dernière et
c'est tous ensemble que l'on peut
arriver à améliorer les réseaux
d'observation améliorer la prévision
améliorer la coordination entre les îles
améliorer l'information préventive comme
on informe avant pendant après donc
c'est tous ces sujets qui sont abordés
bien évidemment aussi comment on met de
la recherche là dedans pour faire
avancer les choses
comment on mais aussi des
télécommunications comme on travaille
avec le secteur privé c'est tout
stressés qu'ils le champ c'est un vaste
champ et s'est basé sur sur des
procédures pourtant très très carré on a
dans la région alors cessé la région
amérique du nord amérique centrale et
caraïbes dont vous voyez sawaya le
canada de fédérer la paroisse d'agrément
canada au nord venezuela au su de tous
les pays et territoires entre les deux
sons sont concernés et donc il y a ils
sont concernés par ce plan opérationnel
cc sont des procédures qui soit écrit
c'est un pavé de 200 pages qui disent
que chacun doit faire quand comment avec
quels moyens qui fournit des
informations
alors bien évidemment connaît tous ici
le centre national des ouragans nhc à
miami qui a été désigné lui comme centre
responsable de la zone par
l'organisation mondiale météo c'est vrai
qu'il a un rôle crucial
il faut pas oublier que tout aussi vu
peut venir d autres pays qui participent
qui échangent en permanence alors je
devrai de grâce à ce stade que
savons-nous exactement que maîtrise on
nous le plus et dans quels secteurs
devant nous à tout prix faire des
efforts c'est d'abord dans le sur
l'aspect technique
oui l'aspect technique mais alors on le
verra qui n'est pas forcément que
météorologiques paradoxalement ce qu'on
arrive à faire de mieux en mieux
ce sont des prévisions et notamment des
prévisions de trajectoire on l'a vu pour
irma pour maria léonce avec quatre jours
cinq jours à l'avance quasiment quel
secteur des petites antilles allait être
ciblée à l'être impact est bien
évidemment ne faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit il a dit que cinq jours
bien sûr les draps pas le désir ça
martin mais de pouvoir dire cinq jours à
l'avance la moitié nord de l'arc
antillais à risques énormes commencez à
vous préparer
on peut pré positionné des forces et que
le des civils rentrer dans le jeu ainsi
de suite l'anticipation c'est à mot clé
dans la gestion de crise par contre il
est ainsi tournée cirque on ne sait pas
exactement alors c'est pas qu'on sait
pas c'est que on a plus de mal à faire
des progrès c'est à dire qu'on a
toujours du mal à savoir à quel moment
ça va s'intensifier rapidement ses
compétences à va durer combien de temps
ça va durer mais on connaît par exemple
je vais pas dire que c'est moins
important mais vous savez en termes
d'information de la population c'est ça
c'est ça qui est important au final
c'est pas de faire des prévisions pour
se regarder faire des prévisions et des
ro super j'ai fait des belles prévisions
je suis content c'est faux que ça arrive
à la population c'est faux que ça arrive
aux décideurs imaginé pour pour maria ou
courir m'a dit tu disais au début c'est
vrai que ce pourrait être un ouragan
majeur catégorie 3 4
oui il nous avait pas dit que cette
année ragan catégorie 5 et plus ça
n'aurait rien changé dans la préparation
du franchement ça aurait changé dans
l'impact
mais dans ce qu'on pouvait passer à la
population il fallait faire les mêmes
choses les mêmes préparation qu'on fait
habituellement quelques jours ou
quelques heures avant donc c'est pas
forcément là que c'est le plus important
le plus important c'est quand même
d'identifier le plus rapidement possible
et le plus longtemps en avance des
territoires qui sont à risque pour que
toute la préparation est en place sur
quel levier on peut éventuellement jouer
pour être plus pointu sur ce genre de
formation que vous recherchez alors quel
levier et c'est que tous les pays qui
ont les moyens de faire de ce qu'on
appelle la prévision numérique c'est à
dire de la simulation qui nous permet de
bien anticiper
quelle bête la trajectoire de l'ouragan
quelle belle son intensité son potentiel
d'intensification faisait tous ça se
fait bien évidemment avec les gros
calculateurs informatique
il ya des pays qui sont très avancées on
parle souvent aux états unis mais le
centre qui fournit les meilleures
simulations numériques c'est le centre
européen auquel participent météo france
mais aussi les le royaume uni donc vous
savez il ya toujours cette petite
guéguerre les gens pensent que oui mais
les états unis force à météo france psa
bien sûr meilleur tous à cette
traditionnelle classique comité montrent
que c'est absolument faux on travaille
tous ensemble nous fournisseurs nous
météo france le modèle européen aux
états unis pour que ils s'en servent
et il s'en sert le plus souvent ils
l'ont encore dit encore hier le
directeur le nouveau directeur aux
nationaux loken center a montré
clairement le modèle européen a été de
loi le meilleur l'année dernière et
c'est celui qui sert de guide à des
prévisionnistes américaines envoyées n'y
a pas de notion de de rivalité bien
évidemment alors je n'aurai de grâce le
cas de maria en septembre dernier est ce
que c'est un caddie corde est ce que
c'est un nouveau point de départ de tout
ce que nous devons faire ce que dans les
prochaines années
non c'est pas c'est pas alors cas
d'école oui parce que ça sert toujours
super aura d'autres même super il ya eu
hier marc il ya eu maria donc
effectivement les petites antilles
n'avait jamais connu d'atterrissage du
ragon catégorie 5
donc c'est une grande première
malheureusement catastrophique certes il
faut en tirer des leçons sur mes
notamment sur plus que de la
météorologie ces on en tire deux leçons
sur l'aménagement du territoire
notamment c'est fondamental sur les
systèmes d' alerte
jusqu'où ça va augmenter c'est devenu un
cas d'école à dominique ce sont des cas
chez l'homme oui enfin ce sont des cas
selon lesquelles il faut baser et avancé
des réflexions pour pouvoir
je vais pas dire pour que ça se
reproduise plus mais vous savez il y as
peut-être dix ou quinze ans on a eu des
phénomènes comme ça je pense qu'on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup plus de victimes
et je parle pour tous les pays tous les
pays de la zone
bon un pays comme j'ai eu les bahamas
qui nous a fait son rapport hier les
bahamas qui ont eu eux aussi vous savez
comment on commence dans les bahamas il
ferait très très vulnérable par rapport
à la mer par rapport au rôle titre de
petit directement qui sont au ras de
l'eau et qui ont pris des marées de
tempête
aucune personne décédée par par ces
phénomènes là sur deux ouragans qui est
qu'ils ont pris
pareil pour les murs que c'est qu'elle
correspondait accusera capable de les
déplacer des populations en moi
d'attendre encore exactement c'est ça
alors c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il
faut travailler on l'a vu pour les îles
de saint-martin notamment cette partie
là alors un peu moins pour sa marque
c'est comment oui comment mieux
anticiper pour comment mieux protégés
mieux protégé des fois ça veut dire
comment mieux évacuer quelque chose qui
est pas trop dans nos gènes
je veux dire franchement je crois qu'en
martinique ça ne s'est jamais fait on
n'a jamais fait évacuer des populations
par anticipation de l'arrivée d'anne
ouragans alors je n'aurai de gras cela
nous mettons le doigt sur des aspects
peut-être cruciaux de 7 2 7 de ce
secteur d'activité l'arrivée de nora
grand ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire on se souvient de du coup
de gueule de jean noël de grâce
notamment sur les réseaux les réseaux
sociaux disant attention on a bien envie
de savoir
on est très contents de savoir quand
chaque martiniquais sommeil à
météorologistes mais bon quand même
quand même quand même la communication
est ce que vous l'évoquez lors de ce
colloque qui se tient la batelière tout
lundi c'est un sujet crucial à ce que ce
que les américains appellent le last
mile c'est à dire qu'il faut que sur
ceux de cette dernière portion
d'information faut qu'elle arrive à la
population faut qu'elle arrive aux
décideurs c'est la communication et la
télécommunication ces deux sujets
fondamentaux alors qui doit communiquer
c'est l'expert météo ou bien c'est par
exemple l'état qui est en contact avec
vous et qui a les remontées
d'informations avec l'ensemble des
autres services chacun de communiquer
dans son domaine de compétence en france
c'est très clair
météo france fait de la vigilance et
informe sur le risque météo sur son
évolution sur leurs proches d'un
phénomène ça c'est la vigilance à partir
de cette vigilance est d'un niveau de
couleurs le préfet ou et son centre
opérationnel prennent des décisions et
des mesures d' alerte donc le communique
sur l' alerte la fermeture des écoles la
fermeture d'aéroports l'évacuation des
populations
bien évidemment c'est pas météo france
qu'il décide c'est décidé par préfecture
en fonction des informations météo bien
vraiment nous siégeons au centre
opérationnel et nous nous est donc bien
évidemment dans ses décisions mais il
faut que chacun communique
et puis après le rôle des collectivités
le rôle de des maires et des mairies et
est fondamental parce que c'est eux qui
sont en bout de chaîne c'est eux qui
vont être obligés d'aller s'assurer que
toute la population que chaque citoyen
et est informé
mais vous savez à quel point les choses
ont tellement évolué ces derniers temps
avec les réseaux sociaux qu'est ce que
vous faites par rapport à ça je suppose
que vous avez quand même des remontées
d'informations à ce niveau là comment la
population réagit
oui alors là là là c'est voilà c'est une
une faiblesse qu on à météo france
nous ne sommes toujours pas
officiellement présents sur les réseaux
sociaux pour ça veut dire pour le temps
réel pour l'événementiel bien ce que
c'est votre rôle d'être présent sur les
réseaux sociaux est ce que c'est pas par
contre je dirais pourquoi la préfecture
ou bien martinière préfecture et cela
est de santé de la population de la
grande difficulté c'est que c'est pas
être ce réseau sociaux pour faire un
petit peu de juste du corporate et puis
dire ah ben voilà on fait si on fait ça
on était à telle réunion en nous si on
est sur l'a2 sociaux c'est aussi pour
parler de ce qui se passe du tour
dangereux faire un petit peu plus
d'éducation d'explication tout ce qu'on
peut pas faire dans un bulletin que que
vous diffusez vous avez bien vu quand
tous les ans un bulletin pour la
martinique sé on n'arrive pas tout
expliquer on peut pas faire de la
pédagogie on peut pas se baser sur
d'autres exemples c'est on n'a pas le
temps de faire ça sur les réseaux
sociaux on peut illustrer on peut
expliquer on peut espérer une meilleure
compréhension et on sent plus courts et
si vous voulez toucher par exemple les
jeunes qui sont sur ce match at me est à
g avec par exemple sur le modèle s'est
dit message de neuf secondes c'est de la
vie des formes et des petits dessins
pour intéresser c'est cette population
bien particulière comment c'est renvoyé
le débat à travers ces à travers de tels
colloque
alors on va on va on parle beaucoup de
socios justement il ya des pays qui sont
beaucoup plus avancés que nous
pendant que le trinidad et tobago il ya
très longtemps qu'ils utilisent les
réseaux sociaux qu'ils ont ciblé des
populations nous on est un petit peu la
trade parce que je pense qu'en france
toutes les institutions eu un petit peu
peur au début de ce2 se mettre en avant
comme ça je crois que maintenant ça
s'est passé mais il faut s'organiser
alors c'est un projet que je porte la
aux antilles que qui devrait aboutir
avant la prochaine saison je l'espère
pour que météo france martinique météo
france guadeloupe soit présence sur les
réseaux sociaux et parle de proximité et
parle aux martiniquais par le
guadeloupéen de ce qui se passe de ce
qu'on fait et de lutter dans la zone et
de la proche des ouragans sait quelque
chose
alors bien évidemment tout ça soit aussi
en coordination avec les autres pays et
c'est de cela dont il s'agit pas qu'on
mette sur des réseaux sociaux quelque
chose pour pour la martinique et que
pour la dominique les réseaux sociaux
disent complètement autre chose
donc cette coordination en temps réel
elle est aussi fondamentale et c'est
aussi au coeur du sujet de ce comité d
oregon
est-ce que vous travaillez au niveau
mondial sur les appellations
ici on parle de ragan de l'autre côté de
la planète à l'os et en océanie en parle
de deux cyclones et ans par exemple est
ce que là il ya une harmonisation à
faire aux savoirs de qu'on parle
exactement est ce que c'est possible
parce que il faut jouer cette carte
alors cette carte on a joué déjà dans ce
grand bassin qui quand même on l'a dit
amérique du nord amérique centrale car
et voyez des problématiques différentes
des langues différentes cultures
différentes des cultures des enjeux
différents et pourtant c'est très très
bien coordonnées par ce comité avec des
appellations qui sont les mêmes avec des
listes de prénoms qu'on connaît tous
d'ailleurs c'est lors du comité des
ouragans qui ont choisi les noms des
prénoms qui doivent être en place et ça
sera vendredi
mais ce qui est très difficile c'est de
l'harmoniser autour du monde parce que
vous l'avez dit il ya tout un passé il
ya le poids de l'histoire et le le poids
même de la d2 du du verbe qu'on emploi
du mot qu'on emploie vous savez ici on
parle d'ouragan d'ouragans majeurs
vous allez à la réunion peut-être lui ne
s'était pas longtemps vous savez bien
c'est là bas on parle de cyclone intense
et ça
l'organisation mondiale à essayer
d'harmoniser mais c'est impossible
chacun le travail ducation à faire donc
exactement c'est un gros gros travail
qui doivent l'éducation de la population
alors c'est vrai je suis tout à l'heure
en aparté je n'aime pas le mot éduquer
parce que les gens considèrent qu'ils
sont déjà
du québec c'est pas à nous de le faire
mais c'est éduquer sur cette partie là
sur une petite partie qui paraît tout
simple c'est les risques
qu'est ce que c'est que le risque
cyclonique comment on s'y prépare
comment fonctionne la vigilance comment
je dois réagir par rapport à de
l'information s'était sensibilisation
cette éducation là qu'on doit faire on
ne fait pas toujours bien c'est vrai on
n'a pas forcément toujours les moyens de
bien faire mais il faut qu'on s'associe
avec l'ensemble des services de l'état
avec avec la des halles avec la
préfecture avec les communes aussi
qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer avec la
collectivité territoriale il faut plus
ensemble l'éducation nationale
j'oubliais il faut que tous ensemble on
arrive à améliorer cette connaissance du
risque cyclonique à travers la
population donc la communication ce sera
finalement le plus important c'est sage
de maître mot la communication et je le
redis de télécommunications les
expériences de l'année dernière 2017 ont
montré que la fragilité des
télécommunications met en péril et met
en danger tout ce qu'on peut faire au
niveau vigilance et à l'air donc il faut
être très prudent sur ce sujet merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec nos jeunes au
val de grâce dans son crédit on rappelle
que ce tour se tient jusqu'à vendredi à
la batelière bonne journée